he just yesterday was with Benny Johnson
you know Benny Johnson he's been on the
show many times and they were chatting
about the boycotts of Bud Light and
where this could all lead
Bud Light gotta get your take on the
boycott so you just brought up
Anheuser-Busch Bud light's getting hit
hit as hard as I've ever seen it you
want to drink Bud's light I mean like
honestly that's like them rubbing our
faces in it and it's like these
companies that do this if they never
have any response they're just gonna
keep doing it so if you as a consumer
are like yeah they're basically and and
I mean it's such a fraud with what
they're doing with that like yeah
they're doing that but I'm just going to
keep drinking it anyways well then
they're just gonna keep doing it so I
think we have power as consumers to make
our voice heard and not on every company
because sometimes conservative consumers
aren't going to make a dent in some
companies this one is one if you don't
have conservative beer drinkers you're
gonna feel that and so you know I think
it's a righteous uh I think it's a right
to stay you know some of these
controversies they come up and people
can kind of just say oh well it's kind
of a one-off yet was stupid to do but
it's part of a larger thing where
Corporate America is trying to change
our country trying to change policy
trying to change culture and you know
I'd rather be governed by we the people
than than will companies and so I think
pushback is an order across the board
including with Bud Light will we ever
see you drinking a Bud Light again no I
don't think so
guys you see what I'm saying about how
the the political part of what's
happening in America and the cultural
part are connected again it's not that
important what beer you choose to drink
except if you keep funding the very
things that are against the belief
system that you have they will keep
moving on you and then what is
the norm today with this trans craziness
will look like the good old days
compared to the crazy stuff that they
will be ushering in in 10 years so look
as you know I'm not a beer guy I'm a
tequila guy however there are many beers
out there might I recommend a couple
Florida beers for you how about Florida
man beer I've got a whole fridge stocked
with it for our guests we've got Key
West beer we've got highlight beer
Havana lager La rubia I like that name
there are many Florida beers if you want
to support the good companies of Florida
we've got Funky Buddha there's a lot of
beer out there and why it's not also
like kind of you're the you're the beer
guy around here it's just not good right
it's but is anyone drinking a Bud Light
like that's the best beer I've ever had
I don't know why I'm talking like this
when I'm drinking beer but like it's
known as not a grape beer that's why
kids in college drink it because they
don't have any money so just goodbye
sorry sorry Anheuser-Busch sorry Bud
Light you stepped in it and we are going
to push back not only politically by
electing the right people but culturally
by putting our money where our mouth is
[Music]
laughs